okay four people joining us on the live
stream we are reviewing some geometric
computing capabilities for the upcoming
version of language all right so we had
already looked at a bunch of things with
polygons right and polygons with holes
and so on that's right and did we did we
confirm wait a minute what is this outer
polygon did I look at so the canonical
form is given us an outer boundary with
any number of inner boundaries okay
and how ever you constructed canonical
polygons will generate that form so if I
were to take this polygon this polygon P
here and I were to say for example
oops know what that did sorry um
and I would say by the way I noticed
that there are no predictive interface
things here which is kind of a shame be
nice if that was possible so what is the
right region difference okay so if I say
region difference a p comma and then
let's say I say triangle is it just
triangle a triangle SSS how do I make a
triangle with three points just triangle
okay so if I say point two point three
you know point five point five point
seven point eight okay now I say
graphics of that oh very Swank oh okay
now if if this had completely opened
this thing what would have happened said
it again if this had completely sliced
through that polygon what would even our
old polygon could have multiple polygons
which are effectively unions I see I see
I see I see so that so that would just
become would that just become a list
there as opposed to I mean if I look at
the polygon itself has multi polygon
inside as a version six
okay so if I look at that okay to
understand that what did that just do so
I see that that had because it wasn't a
hole it didn't have to use right they
did just oh that's nice so it
canonicalized it to not using the hole
yes okay so if I pull that in I don't
even know where where it is but that's
presumably that one there if I say
points six there I need to pull that in
as well
Oh point six to there okay now it's holy
so does rescue okay so now that I say
input for that
how very interesting right so normally
know before we are returning under image
since we didn't yet have a polygon with
holes so we'll update the code and
return a polygon with holes why didn't
that work there silhouetting it it's not
yet fully done okay you working okay
this sir there's a lot of little things
like that to complete well not a lot but
there is you know it's a big system
right but so okay so then have I seen
outer polygons and a polygon before yes
last time okay all right fine
okay um
these are utility functions Stephen
these are easily all of these polygon
coordinates outer polygon unipolar their
utility functions so when polygon
coordinates what does that do I mean in
it gives you the coordinates so if you
have self intersecting curves it will
compute intersection point it will give
you exactly the coordinates used for
that outer inner representation so in
other words if I say list plot or if I
say graphics a point of um this here
that will be all of the oops what the
heck happened there that's nasty
that was a nasty selection problem okay
so what is that that's those are the I
see those are the points those are the
inner points as well as right so those
are those are the corners yes should it
really be called um well let's see um I
mean is polygon coordinates really the
right name for that thing which is
really probably call it we call it mesh
coordinates in for meshes I think
polygon coordinates would be the analog
you know if we build out we're building
out the little subsystem for for for
polygons in polyhedra but does it not
bother you that the polygon coordinates
include random things that are the
wholly parts of the polygons no it
should it should okay no so the point is
then that the rest of it is just a
connectivity structures just a topology
it's it's the correct I see I see I see
so that's like a graphics complex having
exactly like a graphics complex okay
okay
have we looked at these yet and yes we
spent time so crossing and winding pod
no you should look at them um those are
the two constructions remember I did a
presentation last time where we talked
about sort of what defines a polygon
what defines sort of yes points are in a
polygon
so crossing and winding give you a
little bit richer set to constructors
they return polygons now a different way
is random sorry what was that what is
that input thing there that's two closed
curves that are said it's a particularly
complicated example because it has both
oh that's an icon eyes yes I've not seen
an icon eyes that looked like that yet
that's rather Swank how did that know to
icon eyes itself as well we don't know
we do that manually
likewise the least and incopy I see okay
because that's the usual icon eyes yes
okay okay fine um so you see that's a
particularly complicated example right
because the two closed curves both of
them are non simple curves they
intersect themselves yes the membership
is computed on both of those together
for crossing polygons as we talked about
last time right I remember that but so
let's see the the so in practice who's
gonna use crossing polygons it it gives
a case because we support multi polygons
we hadn't done the general case this one
allows you to do that general case when
you have multiple closed curves because
we interpret multiple closed curves as
Union in multi polygons mm-hmm okay so
this is you know and and in the things
that are conventions in different file
formats for what definition of polygons
is used okay okay and in different
systems and we wanted to provide all the
constructors that you could wish for
okay well they're probably a bunch of
cool demonstrations that can be made
with I mean you know you can do get all
kinds of cool effects with this sure I'm
don't forget in your you should
reference opacity from here and things
like that that makes sense because
people who are you know what this is
about is what happens when poly
John's kind of you know are on top of
each other and so on that fair price it
sounds a little weak but can do that
yeah I would reference these things that
have that are about you know how things
go on top of each other okay because
like in that case right this is this is
kind of like a weird negative opacity
type thing in some sense for
visualization purposes I see yes um okay
all right so this let me just take a
look here crossing count so how general
is that I mean can you also do a
crossing count of a region no it's four
polygons in polyhedra
but in principle and the principle yes
but in practice no yet I mean but one
day that should be that would be an
interesting thing to have yes but we're
not there so we shouldn't talk about the
number of times you wind around point
when sweeping the boundary well that's
what I described with the angle criteria
last time yes I think that the most
interesting I mean you should look at
those pages any when you want but random
polygon is is really useful so these are
classes and we can add more in the
future these are important classes
convex and star-shaped is also known as
star convex and simple a simple random
polygon of no arguments do something
useful well that was just something
added for own testing nobody should you
know we just speaking point between T
and 1603 is the minimum right like
do you want to document that it seems
very weird okay by the way if you want
that to not show up yes we need to add a
pattern yeah it seems weird but I guess
what the heck so okay so if you say
graphics of this this is nice I agree
this is useful um why do you say
star-shaped as opposed to star here
given you've got convex simple I mean
star I mean the as always with things
there multiple names for the same things
in the world and star shaped is one star
convex is another for it but maybe we
just call it a star polygon I mean I
don't even understand what this is doing
now why doesn't it what what what's so
star means that it's star convexed it
means that there is a an open region in
the middle from which you can see where
you have a straight ray to every point
in a polygon if it's convex then from
every point in the polygon you can see
every point in the polygon there is a
straight line within the polygon that
goes to that point oh yeah this is
interesting well I see are you rece
entering it to a particular centroid or
what no by default or the example in the
unit box zero one zero one so where you
give the determination we a jaw seat
okay but you're not centering the
centroid no it's another argument we to
put the centroid on zero zero what does
what does regular polygons do it puts
the center at center at zero zero
doesn't it um yes by the way why does
regular polygons not produce one of
these polygons fingy dinghies
and at the time because wanted to be
able to give formulas and whatnot for it
if you have regular polygons of n parent
home okay all right fine but canonical
polygons will do that you know if you
want the polygon okay beautiful okay so
but regular polygons if I'm not mistaken
if I asked for for example centroid why
doesn't that work they just son treat
yeah III sander on our live stream is
agreeing with me that the coordinates
for a random polygons should center
around zero can you explain why that's
not a good idea
no it's pretty arbitrary think that they
could center around zero there could be
in two minus one to one box or something
like that I think that would be a good
idea but I don't think that the centroid
needs to be at the center I don't that
seems no fair enough that that that I
agree with you but that probably doesn't
need to be that but I think it i think
minus one took point probably makes more
sense
oh yeah actually Sandra is making the
amusing point that if you put it in that
if you centered at zero zero you could
use it as a plot marker it's trivial to
do whatever you want with it
if you want to transfer you Center it to
zero zero you translate just translate
polygon and then minus region centroid
of the same polygon so what I would say
I would say translate that polygon - no
no comma yeah well obviously I've got to
go over the hash sign because it's a
random polygon that okay but the thing
that's much more exciting that I'm about
to see is I want to jump to 3d where
apparently you don't have so if I say 1
comma 3 here
so now if I say graphics 3d of that
oh no that that's not what its gonna do
it's gonna do I see
it's a polygon in 3d as opposed to a
polyhedron do we have around a
polyhedron yes although the the is not
yet working on it it will get okay so
these polygons by the way can live in
any dimension three is not the limit no
I understand live in ten D it's fine
something went wrong with that oh I must
have done that I will fix that method
what's what are the method options here
I think it is just fill then right now
or not why but you know people have
different way to somebody so that was
the whole idea in case you know people
who have some specific mate or they want
to use okay hold on one thing that's
hard about these things Steven is that
so here's where I think it will evolve
the good way that if the hard thing is
to characterize the distribution over
the space of all polygons sort of space
of all polynomials fill up that space in
some sense yes hey wait a minute
why is there an inconsistency between
the way that you're specifying these
properties like simple and come back say
I don't think this is right no you're
correct we haven't finished a perdu and
important page and actually the
specification should be based on the
face not on the points yes both of them
needs to be based on face so it means
that they damn consistent so the
corresponding thing to face for polygons
is edge happens to be the same number as
vertices
sorry I don't slam the edges so for
probably the same number for polygon is
the same number but if the language is
going to stay consistent it should be
say edge and set but in general wouldn't
you want to be the case that for a
polyhedron that you would be able to
independently specify the number of
faces and edges and around the
polyhedron
I don't think so why not I mean that's a
degree of freedom isn't it no I'm not
entirely sure but I well didn't think so
I mean yes but though the whole problem
is also you know to be able to sample
them based on on those parameter you're
providing which is most of the kids
impossible so wait a second I mean but
um
yeah by the way of responding to Sandra
on the livestream man a polygon does
have an option for the bounding box
that's what data range is yes um but I'm
sorry I don't understand what why isn't
it an independent parameter right I mean
you got Ellis formula for which connects
the three of edges faces but are you
correct okay but but here we we have a
certain other geometric property that's
not only topology and it's I'm not
saying it's impossible we don't know how
okay to make a random polyhedron you're
saying to make it random polyhedron with
X number of with vertices and because
you can pick the vertices is it the case
that you can pick the vertices kind of
at random right in 3d space and then you
just join the polyhedron is it the case
they're given a set of vertices that
there are there must be a very multiple
polyhedra that join those vertices yeah
many right we're just simple
some are convex etc right and my point
would be that you should just like with
a graph I mean it's not self-evident so
here's what I think we need to do okay
we need to have basically a random
mechanism which we can then prove that
asymptotically provides uniform sampling
into space that we've describing as
you're sampling it right okay I'm not
sure we're gonna we've reached at four
polygons but I'm not sure we're gonna
reach that for polyhedron in the first
iteration fair enough it's not totally
obvious how that would work exactly it
is not totally obvious okay so an if you
look at the page thinking the
application of hand on polygon we kind
of try to explain the distribution that
case in the application section
oh I think cloudy basic skills geometric
problem entry probability
yeah Jim its probability under
applications open a subsection I see so
that's a convex polyhedron that's
interesting I didn't know that sure has
a Gaussian distribution of areas so what
you're saying there right so I mean from
[Music]
from digital to vertically also days of
convergence lesson to think of the shape
okay well fascinating
all right so okay so random polyhedra is
still a bit up in the air yes
okay polygon decomposition so that takes
a complicated polygon and breaks it down
into a union of of simpler ones like
convex ones or and it should be called
polygon decomposition as opposed to
polygon decompose what we call
everything else decomposition
you know hermite the composition Jordan
decomposition yeah
all right seems okay I see them the
default did you have to give a second
argument that says what kind of
decomposition to give notice for should
be just some Pilates yes by the way
Sandra lifestream is complaining that
data range is unusual in its use in
random polygons can you comment or not
that is mean that's not very good at use
but it's primarily used for plot
functions but data range has a vein here
this obvious is something horribly wrong
with the speed of the autocomplete here
mm-hm
and there's something horribly wrong
with the autocomplete itself data range
was introduced originally for vase
functions right what range of actual
coordinates the data should be assumed
to occupy yes yeah that's okay that
that's not unreasonable here that's
that's not an unreasonable thing so I
mean these if the but how does random
polygon but I'm sorry how does regular
polygon work with this oh my god this is
ridiculously slow um doesn't have an
option you just have the center to shift
it translate it well we have a radius
there yes so ultimately we're doing that
and so now for random polygons hmm by
the way are you sure you want the
dimension to be the third argument I
think we discussed that last time and
you said you wanted a rule for something
D goes to spec yeah that would be nice
sir is there a problem with that no no I
think that's fine it's actually kind of
nicer in a way because and spec is held
together more consistently yeah I think
so um should we support a higher
dimensional polygons and regular
polygons why not I mean they're just
gonna go on the but then we need you
know in that case what we need angles or
something well I mean Euler angle is one
out of a zillion ways to specify it yeah
right just but I mean that that the the
point would be this question about
taking a polygon and embedding it in 3d
we don't have a convenient function we
will provide that okay because we that's
how we implementation aliy that's how
everything works both ways it takes
something in higher D project it down
does it planar okay
imbeds back i so you know we will I mean
not 412 but we will design those that we
have convenient such functionality
alright fine fine yeah okay
all right let's continue here um on our
live stream Seth Chandra is asking not
supposed to have a random tiling of a
polygon a random tiling we did that's
we're not doing tilings right now that's
effectively a Voronoi no Voronoi is one
particular type of tiling it's not a
random tiling it's just a right
particular one Seth wants to create
random political districts I see Oh Seth
if you're gonna be here at the
conference we should talk about that
because we'll with many things kind of
brewing there you we keep keen to hear
more from you um is there polygon
simplification flowing 12 ie a polygon
that resembles the original polygon that
has fewer no but there will be so by the
way that particular thing selectfrom
mapmaking you know we had this huge
project so you had special constraints
there there various kinds of constraints
do you want to go into polygon
simplification one is what's called
topological simplification meaning that
you don't get new islands or self
crossings when you simplify and remove
points if you just use a simple signal
processing kind of low-pass filtering
type of algorithm that's what you'll get
you get weird topology in the case that
you did for jump for geography you also
want them to be consistent so if just
define one side of it that the country
next to it as a consistent right I I
don't know why we wouldn't want to
consumer eyes what was done there there
was a lot of work put into that and it
was quite non-trivial I thought it was
mostly manual no no not at all there was
a lot of code written for that and there
were some fancy algorithms that we used
you should you should contact your own
about that see if you can just get that
piece of code and give it a list of
polygons and you should be able to say
simplify well we need something very
production-grade
I mean we're gonna use this a lot
we gonna have not only polygon
simplification but we're gonna have mesh
simplification we're gonna have a lot of
this kind well I you know this was a
significant project we'll get it so yeah
it also has been used consistently for
the administrative divisions of the
world we will get it yes right okay that
presents many weird problems these
administrative division things and
that's very useful to get that
experience from what the weird problems
are right the signatures are problems
right okay
region integration yeah so that these
polygons obviously are fully integrated
with a whole region framework so you're
telling me that if I say of this polygon
if I say this is this is amazing well
that's a graphic okay okay so if I take
a random polygon here yeah and I say
integrate x squared plus y squared X Y
an element of is this gonna work yeah
well not in this virtual well it will
work in the 12 version that we ship it
by the way that's an interesting case
that that is an interesting thing we
should have a small it did you know for
the old polygons it did right it's just
it it's what it takes when we do these
very fundamental changes and this has
been massive on the front inside to know
so at least supporting the cloud right
with their cloud rendering and things
right that is supported isn't it not
sure but oh for God's sake don't tell me
somebody forgot that we can I make sure
that your polygons don't fail in the
cloud right that's like that's very cool
by the way that that worked okay okay
several very very major points here
okay so Sushma go trace the cloud people
immediately and make sure that these
because they don't yet have a version 12
running in the cloud and they were not
aware I think of something as major as
this the
go wrong yes yeah I can check that but
is this in the master branch because I
think they're checking the master branch
it will be soon after this when we're
done with the reviews okay yeah okay
second issue minor point but we should
probably have a version of summary boxes
that goes to a smaller size when it's in
a subscript position I've never seen one
in a subscript position before but it
looks kind of silly that makes sense
Sushma that's something for I guess it I
okay take a screenshot of that yeah can
we use I can eyes at that point
something like I can eyes I mean well
yes I don't think we would want to use
ionisers that is an interesting idea
it's an interesting idea to do that to
do auto-ionization of something where it
gets too insane a subscript but I think
it's a simple thing here it's like
images that will get smaller
you know get smaller on a list and so on
okay um okay well that's very impressive
at all of that works okay let's keep
going down here polyhedron okay so did
we look at this already at all or not so
we did a first look but you can sort of
take just follow it from top to bottom
and you'll see that everything lines up
exactly the same way we learn it so if I
say polyhedron of dodecahedron for
example uniform fully is on uniform why
doesn't that work well because this is
the object you know okay but what
happens if I say but I mean I don't see
why we wouldn't make that work just as a
courtesy
it's like saying graph of Peterson craft
nice tree work since slightly hot
alright fair enough okay so if I do this
for example boy this is a mess isn't it
because this is returning graphics right
yes but there will be another return 400
you can request but an audition is what
the default is
yeah well I think I think maybe we could
survive maybe if polyhedron data by
default produces something which at
least has some visual appearance it
might be okay even without it just being
a pure graphic but how would I get your
kind of polyhedron and as one of these
guys as your kind of polyhedron so right
now is it is it hooked up Charlson yeah
let's try it maybe we recover this one
if you you know you called you Joe so
uniform polyhedron of two won't break
well that but but also polyhedron data
polyhedron data is more of a little bit
more random collection of things legit
support okay
but but what makes something I mean I
don't know on in polyhedron data
I understand there's an infinite number
of polyhedra and we've just picked
particular named ones right you know so
I mean did the particular class of
uniform you know there 24 of them in
polyhedron day that are 72 or 75 total
that we every one which we will backfill
into polyhedron data presumably yes when
we have them yes um but is the rhombic
hex code region one of those yes I mean
from the picture is a uniform one I mean
is the possibility of returning a region
out of if you do region of that pool
yard one you attend something which I'm
sorry from do you know what you do that
- yes but you didn't do what Charles
said but that works too okay
common region here if you if you
region around it I see okay one that
yeah that one okay by the way is the
graphics fix that's that's making
tighter bounding spheres working anybody
know when that's coming in no I've seen
I've seen the branch from use of it at
all no yet okay but hopefully that will
work for regions as well as for other
things that will automatically work for
regions is that true you don't have to
do anything different to make it work
for regions as it works for 3d graphics
I think that what that does is supply
that you can give an argument as a
bounding sphere or bounding ball now
what I think the define that then the
different functions need to actually use
that so it will just automatically work
okay so and then you have to actually
compute that ball don't know but I
thought that the default for 3d graphic
well okay so that needs to be checked
into so you understand it can deal with
points okay so from points we can easily
compute a bounding sphere the minimum
bounding ball yeah the main ball thing
remember okay and in general it's very
hard to know and there aren't always we
have infinite objects so there aren't
always bounded how do I get the min ball
of this thing region bounds and then
that Feynman ball or bounding region
sorry bounding region region bounce is
too simple one bounding region I mean
you should use the mesh wand this
village will not work yet okay okay so
there long lists that we do to to update
the framework yeah and to support new
objects um I know it's complicated
okay anyway that's just another one okay
let's keep going here okay so so for
example if I say canonical polyhedron of
this guy well how do I get that guy to
be a polyhedron in your sense can I just
say polyhedron of that thing and those
numbers should I can
but I understand why polyhedron doesn't
just work no we can support that too
there I think so
um okay so now if I say how was I going
to do here I was going to say if I want
to know that number of phases of this
polyhedron what do I do but we don't
have this function for that maybe I
should be one I think we should yeah
polyhedron faces polyhedron vertices
okay we have to be careful because
there's a lot of them we have the
complete thing for meshes and it's just
commitment but but that's just for
elementary usage I mean how do i compute
the number of edges of a polygon well
the number of vertices of a polygon
we've made them all work with the
corresponding mesh functions in which
case you have it right choice that's
what we agreed on we would make we have
we have that complete set of properties
for meshes you know so you can get mesh
count you know and then you say you know
mesh comma to a sort of comma 1 would be
edges you know to 1 elements but I think
we should provide just like we provide
area and volume and things we should
provide those things okay then we'll
design a whole set of functions there I
think so yeah I mean we will be it's
slightly parallel ok there will be drawn
that's fine that there's a general mesh
function makes perfect sense to me hmm
so now if I say outer polygons outer
polyhedron of this that will just show
that will still show the same thing
right it's better because this one has
no voids
yes under on our livestream is pointing
out that sub faces should work for a
polygon polyhedron does it what I go to
say this sub faces
I'm not taking some of those sub values
well but we use them a lot I mean I
think we should reintroduce them for
point line polygons fully aired on for
all Goffe primitive
no it's kind of silly we should have a
discussion about that but that's not
where we should go primarily that let's
please can we can we will not we don't
have time or it's not for version
obviously for version 12 so but let's
talk about that in the future
yes well for the time being yes so that
we know what they are we'll we'll design
a kit okay predicates polyhedron
decomposition okay so polyhedron does it
only work in 3d or does it work it works
in any D greater than three greater than
or equal to three yes okay delete
duplicates supports a tolerance option
good fine okay
oh boy angles okay so that's a new topic
now yes okay so you see the analog
between polygon and polyhedron
right yep okay now it's a new topic
which is angles okay
interesting nothing is ever simple okay
I understand
that makes sense to me okay what's okay
dihedral angle so that's that that's the
2d version yes it's a question from our
live stream about foreign oi mesh are we
getting 3d Voronoi meshes
not yet but polyhedron is a requirement
for that because the cells that you need
for a Voronoi mesh needs to be a general
polyhedron in general make sense so this
is this is part of of dealing with some
of the requirements for that okay what
is polygon angle I'm so different from
planar angle it is effectively a planar
angle but it's it's it's kind of
important to - I mean I'm planner is not
that obvious but is a plan angle so if I
say polygon angle of regular polygon of
seven for example okay cool and then if
I say random polygon but okay that's
cool so if I would say angle path of
course I won't get the same results but
um yeah cool okay that's cool and what
happens if you have a line with a bunch
of joints in it does that does plane
angle or poet polygon angle give
something for that if I have a polyline
I don't think we have anything defined
for that seems like it might be useful
I mean it's so what I think we need to
think
little bit about so there can be only
for the interior points first of all
because it may not be closed well what
doesn't it just have a rule a left or
right hand rule or something for what
which side of the angle path in other
words if the angle path is coming from
if you assume it goes in a particular
order yes there is always which order
the turtle which angle the turtle turns
through which is what angle path is
using right angle path uses relative you
know that's what makes it easy because
you have you move too and you have a new
state and then you turn from that
exactly right but so I'm saying if you
have a polyline that's effectively
defining a steak you have the sequence
of segments in a particular order right
and so the turn angle is well-defined
unless you sort of assume some default
for you when you start yeah exactly
which which which angle path I think has
some way of doing certainly in 3d it has
a way of doing that anyway I'm just
asking so so in planar angle if I were
to have 3d points
what does planar angle do in principle
if they are planar
we should tell you the angle but
currently I think we just support 2d
okay all right so that's another issue
um okay so let me understand why is this
called polygon angle because it's the
angles in a polygon yes it's a standard
concept in computational geometry that
you get the angles in the in the polygon
what on earth is a polyhedron angle okay
there can be two interpretations of what
that is one is the dihedral angles and
one is two vertex angles the vertex
angles are obviously solid angles okay
so if I say here if I say dihedral angle
of this thing right Notah he'd roll
angle is kind of like planar angle it's
not defined for a object okay so if I
say polyhedra angle
so you need to give the point which
gives you the solid angle or the age
which is poly polygon angle seems to be
perfectly happy to take all points as a
one argument form yes that the point
under edge so we didn't really want make
a choice overturn the whole full list we
can't what seems useful to do that given
the polygon angle does that I mean
because otherwise polygon angle okay let
me ask a naive question
okay so Oh index how does it know
whether you're giving it an index or a
vertex point P or an index I so you're
saying that if I give this is there an
index number five or something here oh
my god it's coming from the convent
realization so the conical is shown the
vertices are salted kind of like in your
coffee complex no I understand
what the heck is that thing no it's a
complicated formula they you have you
have exact numbers in there right
oh no yeah they were excited it's all
the way so those things you're confused
by those algebraic numbers there right
okay well that's cool okay I understand
what this is doing now
so okay you know this form here I don't
think it's going to be picked up
correctly by the syntax highlighter are
you sure it's working correctly that it
knows that that's a three argument form
I don't think it will I don't think it
will I think it's also somewhat
confusing for the users I think it'd be
better if you said Polycom are you know
PT or something comma spec I think
they'll be clearer what's going on
okay um what does full exterior mean
well the exterior visits the full
exterior does you know to complete Timo
- pi - Dane DeHaan go okay okay alright
so let me understand dihedral angle on
solid lines so look at the exterior it's
more what you would have in the turtle
case yes yes I understand so why is the
dihedral angle not supported oh I see
that's the analog of a planar angle I
get it okay I get it
okay solid angle the points spanned by
those vectors so if I say for example
this is go this is the way it's written
there it's fairly general eat so if I
say zero zero zero and then I say sphere
points I should get about four pi okay
now I'm confused point 20 so you're
asking for some kind of 20 dimensional
look if I do that if I say graphics 3d
or um no no those are raised those are
those are vectors and they define a
conic hull right and that's um actually
that's one part we actually need to you
haven't really enforce it here because
yeah like you said actually the
projection of those Ray on the sphere
should you know define an actual polygon
a spherical polygon do you know what I
understand the bouquet is Stephen I look
at the illustration the 3d illustration
there you have u1 u2
you three as the vectors yes okay so
those point you know if you those but I
don't it's time whether why this agent
making it
I don't um why this doesn't do it
because here if I've got sphere points
that say I've got five sphere points
here those are points on the unit sphere
right which are vectors get what I'm
saying you have to define the geometric
region right because the solid angle is
roughly speaking the surface area
defined by you know I understand but so
if I were to do that how would I make a
bounding polygon how would I make from
those points I want to see the 3d
polygons I just say that right I would
just say graphics 3d of polygons of
those points it's non planar polygons
obviously now what happens if I say
canonical polygon of that so if I say
how did does it does it remove the plant
non planarity z-- no how would it can
you do that well I mean with some
triangular there's nothing Clank there's
nothing no it's it's it's its orbit it's
very arbitrary it's undescribable larger
so polygon decomposition does not do
this either no um well I don't
understand why my thing didn't work yeah
reasonable points yes we can make we can
make it work but what we need to do what
we really need is that that way John on
the sphere but those points you need
don't uniquely define your wage on on
this year
well how did any of these points I mean
span by so you say if I have three
vectors it would that correct right like
if you take a core the call me D type I
say solid angle 0 0 0 take percent 53
comma 3
well what are those three points but I
said once we're looking at their yeah
let's let the try that looks a little
that minus one and one that I wonder
what the hell that is
well maybe we just have a poke we need
to write when they are you know they may
be collinear or so cheating what you
don't define the stuff so we get the
singularity - yeah well here you've got
minus one and one so those are those
antipodal points right but so so
something has gone wrong in that case
but you should I don't think it's wrong
it's just that the error messages you
know it's not very helpful yes I mean to
antipodal points on the sphere and then
a third point and your claim is that
doesn't define a I'm not entirely sure
Stephen yeah okay define a triangle I
mean if they find that we you know
during the competition of the octant you
should actually recover from there and
just have to tie probably yes okay cool
okay all right so that's angles um what
else should we be looking at here okay
surface area requested by you thank you
there a lot of other updates framework
wise there's been a lot of work and
internal frameworks to update the whole
system what does this mean it will give
undefined when the thing doesn't match
so if I say area of ball without really
what we want as opposed to saying
missing or something like that well it's
not missing but the air okay so region
measure okay will give you exactly what
you expect so area would be infinity for
ball obviously
okay and and and so region measure you
know comp bald comma to which is what
area is a two-dimensional measure yeah
right okay that would be infinity I see
but we think this is better because that
way people will go and figure out that
its surface area yes given that you're
going to return undefined should you not
return a message in this case we called
I think you showed because that way you
know but basically points people to
surface area I think that's right okay
Sandra I live stream by the way points
out that the thing that that case that
we were looking at was a line on the
sphere so it should have zero solid
angle I see well that's what I suspected
but I needed to sort of check it right
there um okay and nothing else we should
look out for these and no I think that
that sort of covers it okay yeah it's
all kinds of other improvements
discretization now covers all primitives
including tubes and other things splines
that's cool and also mesh unbundling
miss region are cutting primitive now
what does that mean so that means they
can just be directly put underground
before before they could be used in show
but now they can also be used in
graphics in graphics 3d okay we have a
question from the live stream I'm
finally getting export to pauvre Hedra
triangulations and other graphics
primitives not in twelve what's involved
in doing that a project it's just me but
but is it is it fundamentally difficult
given what we have or is it is it um I
don't think so we just need to look at
it what we did we did a major update for
anything related to polyhedral formats
when it
a 3d printing project so that was a
major step up there but there are other
framework things that also kind of need
to improve but pobre wasn't you know
it's irrelevant for 3d printing so it
wasn't done at that time okay fair
enough
well a lot of wonderful stuff here okay
I think we without sit for this it looks
great looks really great um don't forget
those little utility functions for
things like counting a number of faces
on a polyhedron though and also I think
that there is some issue with the
integration with polyhedra data which
would be good to look at and I think you
should consider having polyhedra now of
string dodecahedron work although maybe
that's crazy
and maybe crazy we did one sub
collection that is well characterized we
need it we felt that we needed better
parametric constructors easy ones
that's why we did that's why we are
doing uniform polyhedron and and we will
do those updates to polyhedron data so
that better integrates with all this as
well but I suspect that there are more
of these parametric constructors we want
in the future so I don't think it's the
end of it ok questions also in the live
stream about export SVG or d3 okay so
SVG is one that hasn't been touched for
a while and it's more of an internal
kind of issue where that project lands
d3 I don't think we've ever had as a as
an actual formats but it might be
interesting to actually support yes
we've been discussing that with respect
to the cloud so I think that down some
work done there I see hey listen it
really worries me this thing about holy
polyhedra in the cloud we really should
make sure there's no horror there right
so one thing that we focused on is to
get the front end project done because
they're gonna rely on that for the cloud
so if that wasn't done it would have
been yeah I understand but I don't know
what's involved in porting that and
whether they know that they they know to
port it um you're right Oh
full of these yeah okay sounds good all
right so I think Roger you and I are on
again yes immediately about numerix and
it was on the live stream I encourage
for else on the live stream that's
optimization I think a lot of you guys
are interested in in high-performance
scalable optimization and that's what
it's about
mostly all right so I'll see you there
in a couple minutes
Thanks good stuff see ya